good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight here is the main thing
you need to know about Joe Biden he is
82 80 years old rather he was born in
1942 in the first half of the last
century the year Biden was born only 36
percent of American households had a
telephone nearly half of them did not
have indoor plumbing Joe Biden turned 80
last November this fall he will be 81.
if Biden were to serve a second full
term as president he would be 86 years
old in other words four years from 90.
these are not trivial facts about Joe
Biden these are the central facts of Joe
Biden's life Joe Biden's age defines him
and all of us that's true for every
person age is just a number you will
hear people say but they are lying to
themselves age is more than a number
ages an expression of the core
biological reality of human existence
which is that at some point it comes to
a close ages the way that we chart our
progression from birth to death as we
pass from this world as billions before
us have and are replaced by others
they used to be called the cycle of life
no one has ever changed it no one ever
will so our choice is between accepting
a reality we cannot alter or denying
that reality even exists
the Democratic party has chosen the
latter
tomorrow is March 1st that means a year
from today we will be in the middle of
presidential primary season Joe Biden
has given every indication that he plans
to participate in that and that his
party is firmly behind him the DNC has
already changed the primary calendar to
make South Carolina which is a machine
state where the outcome can easily be
scripted the very first contest and that
was not an accident it was done it was
changed to help Joe Biden win
Biden says he's strongly considering
running again Biden's wife of course
says she very much hopes he will run
and most tellingly of all no mainstream
Democrat has announced a run against him
so as of tonight Joe Biden is in the
race for the Democratic nomination and
as of tonight he will get the nomination
and that's just amazing if you think
about it Joe Biden would be 82 years old
on inauguration day that is eight years
older than the average life expectancy
for men in this country so virtually
everyone in his high school class will
be gone by then but Joe Biden will be
just beginning his second term as
president of the United States
would that be healthy for America would
it be healthy for Joe Biden of course
not it's awful
82 year old men should not be running
countries they're not strong enough
mentally or physically everybody knows
that very much including any 82 year old
man you ask
the people around Joe Biden certainly
know that how could they not know that
they watch him and you do too
here's Joe Biden in Warsaw Poland just
last week
the questions we Face were as simple as
they were profound
would we respond
or would we look the other way would we
be strong
it would be weak would be you we would
be would we be the all of our allies
would be United or divided
so we play Clips like that a million
times for you over the past few years we
could play in million more because Joe
Biden talks like that every day at this
point it's how he talks Joe Biden is
losing his ability to speak that's not a
secret it's not something to learn from
our confidential sources and are
bringing to you for the first time
tonight exclusively that is obvious to
the entire world and you'll probably
sound like that too if you make it to
John Biden's age we will also it's not
weird it's natural it's not an attack on
Joe Biden hardly it's an observation but
because it's natural
we have been commanded to ignore it
Don Lamont got suspended from his show
at CNN recently for suggesting that a
presidential candidate in her 50s was
quote Pastor Prime and that's odd really
as a factual matter what Don Lemon said
is true people in their 50s are
literally certainly physically past
their Prime that's a fact take it from
someone who's 53.
so why was that such a controversial
point of all the demented things that
Don Lemon has said over the years
noticing somebody's age is what blows up
his career
yes because that simple commonplace
observation people weaken with age
points to a power that will forever
remain Beyond human authority which is
the power to control time
no matter how rich we are we cannot
prevent ourselves from getting older we
can buy Botox and hair plugs and
facelifts Joe Biden has bought all of
that but in the end we degrade anyway
because we are not God
accepting this fact that we are not God
working within the pre-ordained limits
of nature is the key to balance and
happiness in this human life
ignoring that fact leads to insanity or
in the case of modern America it leads
to the trans agenda and climate theology
if you asked a hundred honest people to
name the things that human beings cannot
control most would list biological sex
and the weather
you can't decide whether you're a boy or
a girl you are what you are born sorry
and nobody tries we might can make a
sunny day you don't manufacture it you
receive it a sunny day either happens or
it doesn't it's not up to you at best we
can try to predict the weather we cannot
determine the weather
since the dawn of time that has been so
obvious that almost nobody's ever
mentioned it but saying it out loud is
now heresy
and that's because our leadership class
is an open war with nature nature is the
final limit to their power and so they
hate it they tell us they're in charge
of human biology even of DNA trans women
are women they Screech meet our lady
Admiral
they brag about how they now control the
weather too hot for you hold on we'll
change that with a green New Deal
and then they tell us of course that age
no longer matters Joe Biden may live
forever we've got AI now
it's all a ridiculous fantasy they have
no such power they can't even keep the
electrical grid running in the state of
California
and then some of them they know that
they know how limited they are which is
why they become so hysterical in the
face of physical reality because it's a
reminder of their limits
do you remember this fall when that NBC
reporter a woman called Dasha Burns
dared to point out that John fetterman's
stroke had damaged him well of course it
had damaged him everyone could see it
had damaged him but to fetterman's wife
and the rest of the democratic
establishment and the rest of the press
Corps saying something like that out
loud was more offensive than any
obscenity
here's an outrage Mrs fetterman
what did the service that she did to not
only my husband but to anyone facing a
disability and working through it and I
don't know how there were not
consequences right I mean there are
consequences for folks in these
positions who are any of the isms I mean
she was ableist
well she's an ableist how Gisele
fetterman because someone had correctly
pointed out that her husband was no
longer able because he had a stroke in
other words reality intruded on Mrs
fetterman's fantasy and therefore
reality itself had to be shouted down
and destroyed
you're seeing an awful lot of this
attitude that exact attitude recently
from the people in charge it's not a
healthy sign
wise leaders recognize the limits the
inherent limits of their power they know
that they're not in control of much
actually because no one is you can
decide what to have for breakfast that's
up to you but you cannot decide to
become a woman you can't choose to live
to a hundred you can't even choose to
think clearly at 80. none of that is
your choice even if you're the president
life unfortunately is a sexually
transmitted invariably fatal condition
that's not a bad thing it's just true
and when you deny it bad things happen
and they are
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight